Dnes tě naučím o rotující kouli, jenže to není koule a nerotuje. V Qiskit in the
classroom si povíme o této kvantové vlastnosti zvané spin, a to pohledem na experiment, který jako první přinesl důkazy pro
její existenci. Vítej v Qiskit in the classroom. V této sérii použijeme Qiskit k prozkoumání základních konceptů běžně
probíraných v kurzech o kvantových počítačích. Každé video bude také doprovázeno interaktivním modulem
odkazovaným v popisu níže, takže se na něj určitě podívej. Dnes si povídáme o Stern-Gerlachově experimentu z roku 1922.
Je to jeden z nejslavnějších experimentů v historii kvantové teorie, protože tak jasně ukazuje, jak kvantový
spin funguje. Ale to nebylo tím, co Stern nebo Gerlach chtěli dokázat. Experiment byl navržen k otestování nového kvantového modelu
atomu zvaného Bohrův model, pojmenovaný po Nielsi Bohrovi, který jej navrhl v roce 1913. V tomto modelu elektrony obíhaly
jádro na diskrétních orbitalech a mohly mezi nimi přecházet pohlcením nebo vyzářením
fotonů. Každý orbital měl kvantovaný úhlový moment, který byl celočíselným násobkem malé základní konstanty
zvané ℏ. V desetiletích 1910 a na počátku 20. let 20. století byla kvantová mechanika úplně nová, tak nová,
že se ještě ani nenazývala kvantová mechanika. Takže ne všichni byli přesvědčeni o Bohrově modelu. Fyzik
jménem Otto Stern ho nesnášel. Nazval model nesmyslem a dokonce pohrozil, že skončí s fyzikou, pokud by Bohr byl
prokázán jako správný. Stern byl tak odhodlán dokázat, že model je špatný, že vymyslel geniální způsob, jak ho otestovat, a
přizval Walthera Gerlacha, aby mu pomohl navrhnout a provést experiment. Ukázalo se, že Bohra nevyvrátil –
nakonec vyvrátil sám sebe. Jejich experiment byl tak jednoduchý a výsledky tak jasné, že to prakticky uzavřelo
debatu: kvantová mechanika vládne na atomární úrovni. V té době si to neuvědomili,
ale Stern a Gerlachův experiment také přinesl přesvědčivé důkazy pro vlastní spin elektronu, což byla
nová základní vlastnost přírody, nezbytná k vysvětlení magnetismu, supravodivosti a velké části
chemie. Dnes tě provedu tím, jak Stern-Gerlachův experiment funguje, co bychom klasicky očekávali
od experimentu a co Stern a Gerlach nakonec zjistili. Pak ti ukážu, jak si můžeš spustit vlastní Stern-
Gerlachův experiment s Qiskit a IBM kvantovým počítačem. Základní myšlenkou Stern-
Gerlachova experimentu bylo najít způsob, jak zjistit, zda je úhlový moment elektronu v atomu kvantován, jak
předpovídal Bohr, nebo ne, jak Stern očekával. Využili faktu, že úhlový moment elektronu by také způsoboval
malé magnetické pole kolem každého atomu. Takže si je můžeš představit jako malé tyčové
magnety. Experiment vypadal takto: byla tam trouba plná stříbrných
atomů a magnetické pole se severním a jižním pólem
zde. Pole bylo silnější nahoře a slabší dole, takže vytvářelo gradient směřující nahoru.
A nakonec byl v experimentu stínítko. Trouba zahřívala stříbrné atomy, dokud se nevypařily, a pak
vyletěly z trouby s náhodnou orientací malého tyčového magnetu každého atomu. Pak atomy
procházely magnetickým polem. Atomy by byly tlačeny nahoru nebo dolů silou závislou na směru
severního pólu každého atomu vůči tomuto gradientu pole. Pak atomy narazily na stínítko. Stern a Gerlach se mohli podívat,
kam na stínítku atomy dopadly, aby zjistili něco o úhlovém momentu elektronů. Stern očekával, že atomy
v experimentu se budou chovat, jak jsem je doposud popisoval – jako malé tyčové magnety řídící se
pravidly klasické fyziky. Klasicky by tyto malé atomové magnety mohly být orientovány libovolným směrem, takže při
průchodu magnetickým polem by mohly zažívat různě velké síly tlačící je nahoru nebo dolů v závislosti na jejich orientaci. Magnet
ukazující ve stejném směru jako gradient by zažíval velkou sílu nahoru, v opačném směru by
zažíval velkou sílu dolů, a pokud by byl někde mezi tím, síla by byla slabší. Pokud by atom ukazoval
kolmo na gradient, nezažíval by žádnou sílu a pokračoval by rovně. Kvůli tomuto
rozsahu možných sil by atomy měly všechny dopadat na stínítko na různých výškách. Vzor, který by vytvořily
na stínítku, by vypadal nějak takto. Ale to není to, co Stern a
Gerlach viděli. Místo toho viděli dvě zcela oddělené skupiny atomů na stínítku bez atomů uprostřed.
V té době neměli správnou teorii k vysvětlení tohoto jevu, ale nyní víme, že to viděli proto,
že každý elektron má určité množství vlastního úhlového momentu ve formě spinu, který může nabývat pouze
jedné ze dvou hodnot. V našem obrázku s tyčovými magnety to znamená, že existují pouze dvě povolené orientace atomových magnetů. Tyto
dvě orientace nazýváme spin nahoru a spin dolů. qubit v kvantovém počítači
připomíná tento typ spinového systému a některé kvantové počítače skutečně používají qubity vyrobené ze spinových stavů elektronu.
Takže můžeme provést vlastní Stern-Gerlachův experiment s Qiskit a qubity v IBM kvantovém počítači. Pojďme
namapovat stav spin nahoru elektronu na stav nula qubitu a stav spin dolů na stav jedna
qubitu. Když stříbrné částice vycházely z trouby, měly náhodně orientované magnetické momenty. My
můžeme modelovat Stern-Gerlachův experiment vytvořením jednoduchého kvantového circuit s jedním qubitem začínajícím ve stavu nula.
Toto se nazývá diagram circuit, kde horní vodič je qubit a operace aplikované na qubit
se zobrazují jako boxy na vodiči. Boxy RX a RZ jsou kvantové gate, které
efektivně otáčejí magnetickou orientaci atomu. Můžeme zde zvolit náhodné hodnoty Theta a F pro otočení
qubitu o náhodnou hodnotu. To napodobuje troubu, která vyplivuje atomy s náhodnou spinovou orientací. Šedý box je
naše měření. Říká nám, zda je qubit ve stavu nula nebo jedna, a posílá toto měření do klasického bitu –
dvojité linky označené C. Tato část je ekvivalentní měření toho, zda je atom ve stavu spin nahoru nebo spin dolů, pohledem na to,
na které místo dopadl na stínítku. Můžeme použít Qiskit primitiv zvaný sampler, abychom experiment spustili mnohokrát, pokaždé s
jinými náhodnými hodnotami pro Theta a f. Po 100 vzorcích dostaneme histogram měření, který vypadá takto: přibližně
50 % času je qubit změřen jako nula a 50 % času je ve stavu 1. To je stejný výsledek, který viděli Stern
a Gerlach – vždy je to buď spin nahoru, nebo spin dolů, nikdy nic mezi tím. V tuto chvíli možná přemýšlíš: „No,
samozřejmě jsme dostali dva diskrétní výsledky – provedli jsme experiment na digitálním kvantovém počítači, který vždy vrací
nulu nebo jedničku." A to je pravda, ale mějte na paměti, že celý důvod, proč kvantové počítače vracejí binární výsledky – vlastně
důvod, proč kvantové počítání vůbec funguje – je přesně tato kvantizace spinu, kterou Stern a Gerlach jako první objevili.
qubity v IBM kvantových počítačích nejsou založeny na spinech, ale mnoho jiných kvantových počítačů ano. Takže provedení
Stern-Gerlachova experimentu na kvantovém počítači nám umožňuje skutečně znovu objevit kvantizaci spinu.
Od roku 1922 bylo provedeno nespočet rozšíření původního Stern-Gerlachova experimentu. Tato rozšíření zahrnují
posílání stejného svazku atomů přes několik Stern-Gerlachových přístrojů, aby se zjistilo, jak se spiny chovají v různých
scénářích. Tady je jeden: pošleme atomy přes jeden přístroj, aby se svazek rozdělil na dva odpovídající
svazku spin nahoru a spin dolů, a pak každý z těchto svazků pošleme přes jejich vlastní oddělené
přístroje. S Qiskit je kvantový circuit odpovídající tomuto experimentu podobný tomu poslednímu, ale se dvěma
měřeními místo jednoho. Zde jsme nahradili náhodné rotace, které napodobovaly efekt trouby, gate
zvaným Hadamard, protože aplikování Hadamard nám dá stejné pravděpodobnosti měření jako trouba,
ale je mnohem jednodušší ho použít. Takže měříme jednou a pak podruhé. A
výsledný histogram měření pro tento experiment vypadá takto, kde bitové řetězce na ose X odpovídají
výsledkům dvou měření. Pokud byl qubit změřen jako nula v obou případech, odpovídá to bitovému řetězci 0 0. Nebo pokud
byl nejprve změřen jako nula, pak jako jedna, odpovídá to řetězci jedna nula, atd. Vypadá to, že pokud byl změřen jako spin nahoru při
prvním experimentu, bude spin nahoru i při druhém. Stejně tak u atomů se spinem dolů. To znamená, že v prvním experimentu
jsme měli stejnou pravděpodobnost změření nahoru nebo dolů, ale druhým experimentem byl výsledek již určen. Takže
dvě stínítka na konci každého z druhých Stern-Gerlachových přístrojů by měla každé pouze jeden bod. Jedno stínítko by mělo
všechny atomy se spinem nahoru a jedno stínítko by mělo všechny atomy se spinem dolů. Pro náš další experiment
začněme s čistě spin-nahoru svazkem atomů. U skutečného fyzického Stern-Gerlachova experimentu bychom toho mohli dosáhnout posláním
atomů přes Stern-Gerlachův přístroj a zablokováním svazku vychýleného dolů, takže všechny atomy vychýlené nahoru jsou
spin nahoru. Teď pošleme tento svazek přes další Stern-Gerlachův přístroj, ale tentokrát otočíme magnety o 90°, takže
gradient pole bude vychylovat atomy, které cestují tímto způsobem, doleva nebo doprava. Viděli bychom
jeden bod nebo dva, nebo něco úplně jiného? Pro tento experiment
spustíme v Qiskit následující circuit. Začneme ve stavu nula, protože náš svazek atomů v tomto experimentu jsou všechny
spin nahoru. Pak tento Hadamard gate vymění souřadnice x a z, takže má efekt otočení
Stern-Gerlachova přístroje. Takže nyní měříme spinovou projekci doleva nebo doprava místo nahoru nebo dolů. Zde dostaneme
histogram měření, který vypadá takto. Vidíme tedy, že spin podél X může také nabývat pouze dvou hodnot,
které můžeme nazvat spin doleva a spin doprava. Tento experiment tedy ukazuje, že pokud měříš projekci X spinu,
který byl předtím změřen jako spin nahoru podél Z, bude spin doleva nebo doprava se stejnou pravděpodobností. Pojďme to naposledy porovnat
s klasickým očekáváním, abychom opravdu zdůraznili rozdíl. Klasicky si vzpomeň, že jsem
říkal, že pokud malý atomový tyčový magnet ukazoval kolmo na gradient magnetického pole přístroje,
síla na tento atom by měla být nulová. Neměl by být vychýlen nahoru ani dolů, v tom případě vidíme jen jeden bod uprostřed
stínítka. Místo toho vidíme dva body, takže polovina atomů má spin doleva a polovina spin doprava, i přesto,
že dříve byly změřeny jako nahoru. Takže z pohledu kvantové mechaniky, ačkoli může být lákavé
ztotožnit spin nahoru s vektorem ukazujícím nahoru a spin dolů s vektorem ukazujícím dolů, není to tak jednoduché, jak vidíme
z posledního experimentu. Abychom skutečně pochopili, co se zde děje, budeme muset jít hlouběji do témat
kvantové superpozice a měření, což bude video na jindy. Stejně jako jsme my zůstali s více
otázkami o tom, jak přesně kvantová mechanika funguje, zůstali tak i Stern a Gerlach. Jejich experiment nevysvětlil
vše, ale šel daleko v ustavení kvantové mechaniky jako nezbytné pro pochopení přírodního
světa. Byl to jeden z nejdůležitějších základních experimentů v kvantové mechanice, který jak dokázal kvantizaci
momentu hybnosti, tak poskytl důkazy pro novou základní vlastnost přírody zvanou spin. Aby skutečně pochopili a
zvládli pravidla kvantového světa, museli fyzici jako Stern a Gerlach ušpinit si ruce navrhováním
experimentů, vytváření předpovědí a někdy i chybováním. Opravdu neexistuje náhrada za to, zkusit věci sám.
Takže pokud si chceš vyzkoušet provést skutečné kvantové experimenty, přejdi na Stern-Gerlachův modul
odkazovaný v popisu. Díky za sledování a na viděnou příště.